the holidays are the perfect time to
give the perfect gift
but it might not always be as easy as it
sounds especially when it comes to the
special pc gamer in your life
but we're here to help so let's check
out some of our favorites
[Music]
consider a keyboard like a weapon you
take into battle
you'll want to make sure you have the
perfect one equipped at all times that's
why the corsair k100 keyboard
makes our list with its aluminum design
per key rgb lighting
optical mechanical key switches and so
much more there are also six
dedicated macro keys that are great for
streamers as it's compatible with
elgato stream deck software and you can
save up to 200 macro and lighting
profiles
and the keyboard also comes with a
magnetic detachable memory foam palm
rest
for comfortable play this keyboard is on
the market for 229 dollars
bug snacks is a new game that will be
available on pc for 24.99 and it will
give the gift of a whimsical adventure
to snacktooth island which is home to
the legendary half bug
half snack creatures in this comedic
adventure fit for any age
there are a hundred different species of
bug snacks to discover and hunt
along with finding the truth behind the
mysterious disappearances
on the island consider this game if
you're looking for something light and
fun for the holidays
the steel series arctis one wireless
gaming headset
is a perfect all-around headset that can
be used on many different platforms
it also has a detachable noise
cancelling mic and will have
many uses as you can also take it on the
go you won't have to worry about
durability
as this headset is equipped with a steel
reinforced headband and has a 24 hour
battery life you can get the arctis one
for 99.99
keyboard check headset also check now
let's talk about the mouse
the razer deathadder v2 pro gaming mouse
comes equipped with a 20k
dpi optical sensor that is actually
three times faster than a mechanical
optical switch
it can even reduce cursor drift from
liftoff to landing to help provide
pinpoint accuracy enjoy up to 120 hours
of battery life in bluetooth mode
or up to 70 hours of ultra fast
performance when switching to hyper
speed wireless
this lightweight design is optimal for
any fps gamer and is 129.99 we've got
another headset
option for you if you're looking for a
premium usbc headset the creative sxfi
gaming headset is specifically designed
to optimize gaming audio
with super x5 technology and a pro grade
commander mic
we even tested out this headset when it
debuted at ces
and earned our seal of approval you can
snag this headset for 129.99
here's another game that is perfect for
the pc gamer you're shopping for
if you want to give a little fright with
the festivities the medium
is a psychological horror game where the
puzzles and mysteries are solved
in dual reality meaning the entire game
is rendered in two worlds
running simultaneously at all times
scary or not this
patent and dual reality gameplay is the
first of its kind and a great gift idea
for 49.99 there's a few of our favorite
gifts that will be a great choice for
any pc gamer
if you want to see even more gift ideas
then be sure to check out our full guide
at gamespot.com
happy holidays everyone